ich habe zweimal hingesehen und zwar ist
es in dieser woche die wende in dem
aktuellen wahlkampf genauer gesagt die
spd nicht nur die umfragewerte sondern
auch heute die präsentation des neuen
spd tv werbespot man muss sagen der spd
gelingt etwas sie schafft es ihre ganzen
debakel der vergangenheit wirklich unter
den teppich zu kehren bei dieser
kampagne ist auf einmal von g-20 chaos
in hamburg nichts mehr zu sehen von
wirecard nicht zu hören von hartz4
ebenfalls nicht gleichzeitig hat sie
eine wirklich clevere strategie ist
geschlossen und ich glaube wenn die spd
das weiter durchzieht und schafft dann
könnt ihr am ende sogar der wahlsieg
gelingen keine rechts links debatten
mehr keine großen skandale sondern
einfach nur fürs kanzleramt kämpfen und
ehe die runde jetzt sagt na ja da sind
ja auch noch kevin kühnert und saskia
esken da möchte ich sagen das ist für
mich kein argument ich finde die haben
sich in letzter zeit zurückgehalten und
es zeigt eigentlich dass die gegner
immer auf diesen punkt gehen das
attestiert olaf scholz dass er der
stärkste kandidat ist ich glaube
regieren ist ein allheilmittel am ende
werden sie alle zusammenstehen
das thema kevin kühnert ist ein gutes
und auch saskia esken und weiter norbert
walter borjans aber das jetzt gar nicht
mein punkt mein punkt ist eigentlich ein
anderer das auch olaf scholz und du hast
ja auch gerade gesagt er wäre gemäßigt
und hat die partei auf gutem kurs
gebracht das auch olaf scholz und auch
sein generalsekretär las klingen weil
ich in der lage sind zu sagen mit den
postkommunisten und mit der partei die
in teilen vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird mit den koalieren wir
definitiv nach der bundestagswahl nicht
das haben wir heute auch wieder gehört
hat angestrichen manuela schwesig werden
lars klingbeil hier bei uns im studio
und beide haben sich gefunden beide
haben gesagt wir suchen eine koalition
der stabilität aber was heißt denn
eigentlich stabilität wir wissen dass
ungefähr ein drittel der abgeordnete der
linkspartei im bundestag aktuell
zumindest
mit der organisation sympathisiert die
vom verfassungsschutz als
linksextremistisch zumindest beobachtet
und eingestuft werden und das doch ein
riesenproblem mit demografische partei
wie die spd nicht bei dir ich würde
trotzdem sagen ich glaube nicht dass das
die bevorzugte koalition von herrn
scholz ist wer ihm aufmerksam zuhört
gestern war bei uns abends im interview
und dort hat er rein von seiner
inhaltlichen ausrichtung eigentlich
ausgeschlossen mit der linken soll das
ausschließlich moment aber die anders
aus sagt habe die sind endlich geeinter
als endlich ruhe wenn der jetzt die
bombe zündet dann kommen wieder fünf
einer seite und sagen moment mal ich bin
der linke flügel fdn er sich die fw wird
vom verfassungsschutz beobachteten es
gibt eine brandmauer der demokratischen
parteien zu saft die vollkommen korrekt
warum gibt es bei der spd diese
brandmauer nicht zu einer anderen partie
jetzt mit img hat man
verfassungsexperten nicht beobachtet
wird die wird ja nicht die wurde mal
dass es gibt wurde dann form erhalten
ein drittel aber in einer extrem stimmt
der extreme politiker niedersachsen die
auch seit diesem jahr wieder vom
verfassungsschutz akten über keinen
überschäumenden emotionen das ist dabei
die einheit weil wir sind hier weil wir
alle fall ist weil es bei den fans ist
ein herrlicher ist dass olaf scholz der
letzte ist er mit der linkspartei eine
koalition haben nein das sagt er deshalb
aber warum denn nicht weil er deren
wähler holen will jeder hilfe hat
gehören der hat doch mit der afg regen
das will niemand hören dass die stadt
sich als lager stellen das ist nicht das
will niemand aber ist mannheim wo er den
de gaulle link die links hat die
linkspartei liegt im moment bei umfragen
seit langer zeit bei 7% sie wollte
zweistellig werden sie würde es nicht
mehr und warum wird sie es nicht weil
sie selber schwach ist und weil weil es
eine einzug von linken wählern übrigens
auch von den grünen weg hin zur spd geht
warum ist denn die spd so stark geholt
doch keine wähler bei der cdu sondern
die holt die wähler auf der linken die
wird eine art von links das ist ja nur
gut gemeint ich übrigens wenn ich zudem
habe man sollte meinen sie können
reden
natürlich eine sehr intelligente
geschichte nutzt ihre these da läuft
olaf scholz mit malu dreyer am arm rom
hamit machten aber aber nicht mit
fresken also die tauchen gar nicht auf
also die pilze bube und und pilze damen
ministrabel hat er gesagt und damit ist
es doch eine super intelligente antwort
weiter so herr scholz doch doch niemand
der aus dem bauch heraus dass man ebenso
entscheidet der wird sich gedacht haben
ich bin sie ein erster
leute kandidaten mit dem er nichts gut
klarkommt rivalen einzubinden und
gleichzeitig kann sie doch nichts mehr
sprengort merkel doch genauso macht
erster koalitionsausschuss hat hier saß
carsten glas wein macht ihr bei mir im
büro gemütlich hat sie sich die ganzen
herangerückt dann waren die freundin und
es gab auch kein wir gehen aus der
gruppe heraus ja das gleiche macht
urlaub stolz doch jetzt gerade in
fataler weise
genau ich kann nämlich gerade wir reden
nämlich sehr viel und sehr detailliert
und das ist ganz toll über personalien
sagte ja es ging ja aber gerade haben
sie einen einwurf gemacht und ich glaube
diesen einwurf fragen sich alle bürger
mit den inhalten wie habe eigentlich
schon den besten gelernt von der cdu
2017 das thema integration migration
spielt überhaupt keine rolle bei der cdu
und man verkauft uns die bürger und
bürgern für dumm und wenn wir nicht
darüber reden dann verschwinden die
themen übrigens werben aber das ist noch
vorher gesprochen genau diese ideologie
ist auch bei der zb spd und die grund-
und die linke wenn du hast den übergang
so
haben sie wissen es nicht auf die ebene
holen sollten im wahlkampf nicht mehr
inhalte als person zählen dass wir also
die ganz große frage aber das ist die
ganz große frage weil ich fand diesen
einwurf von ihnen ich glaube das
empfinden so viele bürger journalisten
sollen nicht für bürgerinnen aber ich
empfinde das als ohrfeige
ich bin gern journalist ja ich weiß
eigentlich dass sowohl einfach visier
eingebaut haben wir die beiden über die
persönlichkeit sgs und olaf scholz und
sie werden einfach ein was ist mit den
inhalten im moment aber steht nicht olaf
scholz von den inhalten frage jetzt auch
an die videos zu sehen ich sag mal so
steht er nicht eigentlich für merkel
politiker da nicht eigentlich ohne viel
zu sagen alles gesagt aber da würde auch
mehr
doch uns einig oder mach doch gerade
daraus er machte merkel
weiter so kontinuität im
willy-brandt-haus sagen sie inzwischen
wenn er ohne auf den ganzen tag einfach
24 stunden für einfach erfahrung und
kompetenz steht sind wir alle zufrieden
da sieht man doch wo die messlatte
hänger da ist aber besser als merkel
denn bei der vils inzwischen an
kompetenz muss ich einfach sagen die
frau ist überfällig er ist besser als
sie jetzt in der augen sind ja nur noch
3 3
das erstaunliche ist ja dass die spd
total still hält es gibt überhaupt
keinen einwurf von der seite kein
vorschlag keinen kein interview dass ihn
stört keiner der in tritt von hinten von
der seite von oben auf den kopf schlägt
nichts herr kühnert ist sturm die
statistiken ist die pille danach wie
revolution ihre
pfunde verlieren jetzt vom immerhin
funktioniert ja ja ja noch der meinung
von frank und herr jörges hier in der
runde nein es gibt jetzt neuerdings den
bogen an den anderen seite zu schlagen
die cdu es ja auch total stimmt
allerdings ist es daher sehr schädlich
genau das jetzt der kandidat ganz
alleine und beschwert sich im
hintergrund dass alle in die brüche
gegangen so jedoch ein punkt her aber
sie hat es geschafft ja eine sehr
unruhige partei zu einer one man show
quasi darum machen oder eine one man
show aus diesem wahlkampf zu machen also
schon irgendeinen dreh lamina das
gegenteil von mentschow ja der braucht
halt keine rolle aber näher brauchten
der 59 oder 60 oder mit ganz vielen
frauen show das ist dass er bräuchte ein
team das er nicht bei herrn will während
der scholz 1 benennen darf weil sie sind
kaputt machen wir olaf scholz hat nicht
rücksicht auf die partei genommen hat
gesagt ich mache was ich für gut halte
und armin laschet nimmt zu viel
rücksicht auf die partei auf die
kanzlerin auf die minister im kabinett
deswegen hat er auch kein thema nach
davon ableiten dass wenn er das jetzt
schafft im wahlkampf dann hat er ja
scheinbar nicht wie schröder das basta
aber er hat seine eigene art was dazu
sagen wenn er sich jetzt durchsetzt
warum sollte er sich anschließend so
eine regierung nicht auch durchsetzen
und glauben auch in diese richtung
glaube dass er wenn er vermutlich müsste
er ja mit zwei parteien verhandeln und
über eine koalition und das dann so
dachte anders geht auch ein rechnerisch
war das ja ich glaube nicht mehr dass
man eine groko kriegen dafür reicht auch
nicht mehr gottlob ja aber eine drei
parteien koalition wenn man vermutlich
kriegen von dass das land hier
ineinander kanzler der die bildet der
ist dann auch angesichts von drei
parteien relativ frei in der
zusammensetzung des kabinetts das
handelt er mit den beiden anderen aus
und da kann herr kühn und dem
hintergrund sagen was er will hat wird
im kabinett nicht angehören vielleicht
wird der staatssekretär und damit zu
einer personalie und das ist ja überall
so olaf scholz johanning laschet
aberglauben glauben sie nicht oder ich
glaube dass so sehr die politik muss
doch mal über inhalte ich würde ja ich
glaube viel zu sehr wird könnt ihr über
das wort plan beschleunigungs verfahren
sprechen das war ja bisher der
wahlkampfschlager
lahm beschleunigungs verfahren sie
erinnern sich ja das war bei tesla gibt
so viele barrieren ist ja richtig
aufwärts mit den nazis mal in
wahlkämpfen ist es oder geht es um die
frage brauchen wir einschlagen urlaub in
deutschland das ja vor rente wohnen
direkt booms das glauben die leute so
bekannt aber nicht vor auch nicht her
wenn ich das immer auf dem wahlplakat
lese faire löhne starke renten abhängig
machen ist auch bei schweizer stärke ich
bin heute ein amt habe extra vor der
sendung einmal geguckt da hängt die cdu
und wir wissen ja nun alle oder es wurde
berichtet dass die ihre eigenen
mitarbeiter eben verkleidet haben sage
ich mal salopp da stand eine eine
polizistin so und drucken war scholz und
dann dachte ich so ja gut da das prägt
sich ein da weiß jeder wer gemeint ist
ganz andere visuelle darstellung des
smart gemacht einfach ist die die wie
riesige problemlage deutschland ist
riesengroß weil wir es seit einigen
jahren mit einem dramatischen
staatsversagen zu tun haben mir
funktioniert ja nichts mehr darüber
müsste eigentlich diskutiert werden das
dafür sind alle drei kandidaten zu
schwach die werden den teufel tun das
auch noch sozusagen auf die tagesordnung
den gibt es im moment nicht das ist dass
das ist das buch das sind keine gekommen
das kann ich schon mal da kann ich in
diesem abend das entwickelt sich niemand
fängt haben konnten entschuldigen sie
als bürger habe ich eine meinung dazu
welchen kandidaten nicht zutraue mit
dieser verheerenden lage des landes klar
zeigen und geraucht habe ich muss auch
noch irgendwie ein bisschen optimismus
in der zukunft sehen und wenn ich aus
dem ganzen tablett dass da jetzt an
kandidaten steht was sehe und auch
merkel sie haben von 16 jahre gesagt
vielleicht braucht unser land einfach
öfter wechseln
abschluss eine umfrage noch mal in die
runde herr jörges ab wem würden sie es
zutrauen einnahme von den drei
kandidaten niemanden ist sie auch sonst
niemanden das ist mir sind in so einer
phase wo keine lichtgestalten mehr zu
erkennen ist gibt es bestenfalls
die wahl gewinnt armin laschet wird es
noch drehen und das ist ihm auch zu
engagieren also ich glaube dass die
union am ende die stärkste partei wird
und damit wird dann armin laschet
mutmaßliches bin jetzt bin ich relativ
langweilig
hermann solar oder gerne und politisch
bleiben aber als jetzt brach aggression
mitglied der diskussion würde ich sagen
nahm mit laschet wird es doch schaffen
so 40 sagt olaf scholz macht das ding
und zwar mit sicherheit zwischen es wird
sich zwischen laschet und scholz
entscheiden aber ich glaube olaf scholz
wird das am ende schaffen ob er dann
auch die ganzen koalitionsverhandlungen
leicht und schnell von der bühne gehen
das glaube ich nicht aber ich setze da
doch auch scheiß ich glaube dass das er
gerade
einen lauf hat da gehen wir die zweite
welle des arznei genau gleiche gleich
mit mit friedrich merz eine wette dass
die union 30plus kriegt ich habe ihnen
gesagt ich darunter jetzt die zweite
unionswähler finde ich mehr auf sie
wartet auf 30 plus ja wir müssen ein
bisschen her aber
angeschlagen braucht er so da nämlich 14
so ist 4 zu 1 eine gute quote was haben
sie dagegen in der wette ich schon ich
darf mir noch interviewer ausdenken der
handtasche hätte ich hier verlangen ich
bin nicht käuflich bei mir gibt's eine
flasche sekt soll des urlaubs werden
gibt es eine flasche sekt für frau
defekt oder selters ist wie bei der spd
in diesem wahlkampf es gibt kein
champagner der sekt ist die spd der rest
des alters